hey everybody my name is vladimir
duthiers I'm a CBS this morning
correspondent and it's a real treat for
me to be here because we are coming to
you from the site of the CBS News
democratic debate and no I am NOT going
to be one of the moderators even though
I'm seated or at least very close to the
desk where our moderators will sit of
course our moderators will be co-host of
CBS this morning Gayle King and the
anchor and managing editor of the CBS
Evening News Norah O'Donnell they would
enjoined by matron Garrett it will be
joined by the Winokur of 60 minutes and
Margaret Brennan of Face the Nation all
five will sit here on this set and over
here as we make our way where there's a
beehive a bevy is a beehive is it a bevy
of activity that is happening here on
the set as the staff and crew gets ready
for it debate you can see the podiums
where all the candidates will be seated
tonight very very exciting show you the
podiums where all of the candidates will
appear starting with former New York
City Mayor Bloomberg right here the end
businessman Tom Schneider so this is
where we're gonna be showing you this
debate from Gilyard Hall and I thought
would be really really cool is away from
the politics cause you're gonna get
plenty of that tonight is to tell you
why we chose this place and what makes
gillard Hall so special so waiting to
talk to us is the vice president of
marketing and sales here at Gilyard call
Stephanie shapes she's gonna give us a
little bit of the history of the place
and what makes it so special
let's go so Stephanie you are and vice
president marketing
iq at all what one of the things that I
wanted to impress upon our audience is
how special the building itself is is
quite old although the interior has been
upgraded updated upgraded upgraded
[Laughter]
original building was built in 1968 it
was a municipal auditorium and after
several years here in Charleston they
decided that they wanted to update the
building really make it a place for the
Performing Arts and so one of our
wonderful patrons mrs. Ingram went to
our mayor
airily and said hey I want to be a part
of this we think it needs to be a
special place Charleston is really a
place for the Arts if you're familiar
with the Spoleto Festival of course sure
sure
so we under nan to a public-private
partnership and they created the
Charleston Kelly Art Center which you
see around you which you showed everyone
today and so part of that though was a
public-private partnership which is a
very different thing so the city of
Charleston put in part of the money and
private citizens put in part of the
money so that's what created what you
see today but under winning and that
magnificent renovation and created this
acoustically designed performance hall
but we also are a nonprofit which is
what we were not before so we're
actually a nonprofit organization that
creates arts education we go into all
three three school systems in the low
country and we bring barrier-free arts
education to every student unit thank
you so much for sharing all this with us
yeah this is great we're so excited and
in just a couple of hours the CBS News
democratic debate will take place on the
stage behind me again reminder it will
be moderated by CBS evening news anchor
and managing editor Noor O'Donnell Gayle
calicos of CBS this morning she they
will be joined by major Garrett our
chief Washington correspondent Margaret
Anne moderator of Face the Nation and 60
minutes Bill Whitaker hope you guys will
tune in and hope you got a good sense of
what it is that where it is that we are
for having me on hourly briefing yes
thank you very much we'll see you guys
soon